retour en france nous sommes en pleine
période d'examens demain et mardi les
élèves de 3e passent leur brevet une
grande première dans leur scolarité
non sans stress voici des élèves qui ont
la chance d'étudier sans jamais avoir à
franchir la dure étape de l'examen
il s'agit des étudiants l'université
populaire de caen créé il ya trois ans
gratuite elle est ouverte à tous à tous
les âges
le plaisir d'après marianne tichot gens
me regardaient il y a trois ans michel
onfray quitté l'éducation nationale pour
donner corps à son rêve dispensés
gratuitement à savoir au plus grand
nombre
université populaire ne délivre pas de
diplôme on a fréquentes juste pour le
plaisir de la connaissance fils en
classe terminale
mais comment la grande obsession du bac
soit on a fait des études à l'université
soit ces anciens soit on n'a pas fait de
vieux os fille parce qu'on n'est pas
allé jusqu'en terminale
donc là c'est une proposition vraiment
populaire qui est fait aux gens nous
avons voulu faire de la philo on va en
faire ensemble ils disent le doute parce
qu'il est mise en avant ne cesse dufour
fausses certitudes
le politiquement correct quoi pour le
dire comme ça vous avez un petit et
primo quelque chose et bien sûr
sur la philo c'est aussi bien et c'est
ce que donne michel onfray depuis le
début et je crois qu'il a raison c'est
quand la peine d'aller d'aller se faire
travailler par des psychiatres
alors qu'il se fit effectivement 2
avoir une logique de penser aux videurs
de vivre normalement
la philosophie j'avais jamais eu
l'occasion de l'aborder mais finalement
je pense que dans la philosophie et
beaucoup bon sens le monde change et une
espèce de globalisation de
mondialisation il ya beaucoup de
questions par beaucoup de réponses on ne
croit plus beaucoup
réponse religieuse ni les questions une
question de n'ont pas l'impression donc
d'être résolue politiquement je pense
que les gens comprennent que la
philosophie peut faire ça c'est à dire
peut permettre de répondre aux questions
qu'ils se posent à côté du grand amphi
la salle des enfants
et là c'est une autre façon de
philosopher en fait si turcot recopie ce
que ce que quelqu'un d'autre a fait tu
exprimes sa vie on est à raison quand on
répète une oeuvre de quelqu'un on
exprime c'était cette personne qui a
écrit l'oeuvre a voulu exprimer
l'université populaire n'est pas là pour
leur enseigner des systèmes de pensée
mais pour leur apprendre à débattre à
confronter leurs idées sur des thèmes
qu'ils choisissent poser des questions
réfléchi raisonné ça implique un travail
mais on s'amuse bien aussi on peut d
christian c'est pas comme les cours ou
les cours c'est plutôt une travaille on
travaille tout le temps que là c'est
aussi une ambiance
les enfants sont naturellement
philosophe et qu'ils sont tous à même
ils ont tous si vous voulez une
propension naturelle à questionner le
monde durant deux heures qu'il soit
petit ou grand il partage la même soif
de philo est loin de l'enseignement
classique
université populaire a trouvé une libye
les personnes nées ici pour tout vert
justement pour prendre ça utile vraiment
très pragmatique en décrochant un
diplôme un travail quelque chose que
nous avons un large en vue de leur
matériel ici on est juste là pour
réfléchir un peu avec lui
ce tout accord l'université populaire
est reparti pour trois années de plus
d'autres universités à lyon arras et
narbonne ont été créés sur le même
modèle